وزاره الكوارث التركيه تقول بارتفاع عدد
ضحايا الزلزال الى سته الاف ومئتين واربعه
وثلاثين قتيلا حتى الان
62434 قتيلا حتى الان وذلك وفق اداره
الكوارث التركيه معك زيدان تفضل اكمل
كما ذكرت يعني اليوم هذه المباني المجاوره
للموقع هي مهدده بالانهيار في اي لحظه
يعني شاهدتم قبل لحظات التشققات والتصدعات
في هذا المبنى المؤلف تقريبا من 12 طابقا
او 14 طابقا لذلك الموضوع جهود الانقاذ
تستمر بحذر شديد يعني حتى الاليات الضخمه
عندما تعمل هناك عمل بدقه شديده لعدم يعني
اي اخطاء لا قدر الله يمكن ان تؤدي الى
كوارث اخرى غير الكارثه التي نشهدها الان
اي هزه ارتداديه قويه لا قدر الله يمكن ان
تؤدي الى انهيار مباني اضافيه لذلك العمل
يتم بشكل دقيق وهي وهو عمليه صعبه صحيحه
صدقا عادل نحن منذ يوم امس وحتى هذا اليوم
نشاهد هذه العمليه جهود كبيره من فرق
الانقاذ لكن الظروف يعني او طبيعه العمل
صعبه جدا ايضا الحاله الجويه سيئه
يعني لا تساعد كثيرا فرق الانقاذ بالعموم
يعني الوضع هنا في اضنه رغم كل هذه الظروف
التي الصعبه التي نتحدث عنها افضل بكثير
من باقي الولايات الاخرى